ところで、すごく唐突なんですけれども、河野さんは
ビル・ジョイという人物をご存じですか。
はい。サン・マイクロシステムズの
共同の設立者であって、その社の
チーフサイエンティストでもあったかと思うんですが、
情報技術という科学技術の最先端で多大な貢献をした
インターネットのエジソンというふうに呼ばれるような
技術者のことですね。
そうですね。ビル・ジョイは、
21世紀に急激に発展をすると、
そういうふうに考えられる科学技術の分野、
三つの領域なんですけれども、遺伝子工学ですね。
それとナノテクノロジー、それとロボット工学。
この三つの分野をそれぞれ頭文字を取ってGNRと、
こういうふうに呼んでおりますけども、
この三つの領域に注目をして、
自分の専門の領域であったコンピューターの能力が
飛躍的に向上するであろうということで、
そうすると、これらの分野で人類を滅ぼしかねない、
そういう技術が開発される可能性があるということを
指摘したわけですね。遺伝子の工学の分野では、
例えば、感染力を強化した、そういうインフルエンザや、
あるいは特定の人種だけが感染するそういう人造病原体。
こういったものを近い将来に
作ることができるようになるだろうと、
そういう予測をしました。さらに、20世紀を代表する
兵器でありますけれども、核爆弾などが、
これがもちろん大きな影響を人々や
環境に与えるわけでありますけれども、
それにしても一過性であろうと、
それが使われたとしても。しかしながら、
人造病原体っていうのは自己増殖機能っていうの、
これを持たせることが可能になる、その可能性が高いと。
そうすると、自己増殖してるわけですから、
長期的でかつ広範な影響っていうのがあると考えれると、
こういうふうに言ったわけです。
彼は2000年当時でありますけれども、
2030年までには当時に比べて100万倍の能力を持つ、
そういうコンピューターが開発をされると、
そういう予測をしたうえで、その能力を駆使すれば、
ナノテクノロジーやロボット工学においても
自己複製をする、そういう能力を持った、
例えばナノスケールの非常に小さな
人工物でありますとか、あるいは高度の知能と
自己複製機能を持ったロボット。こういったものが
開発されるだろうというふうに言ってるわけですね。
もちろん、これらの技術が人類の福利に
多大な貢献をするであろうこと。
その可能性があるということは認めながらも、ジョイは
潜在的な危険性に強い懸念を示しているわけです。
しかも、これらの技術っていうのは、
20世紀を特徴づけた、先ほど申し上げたような
核兵器の開発のように、国を挙げた巨大プロジェクト、
例えば核爆弾の開発のためにはこれ、
マンハッタンプロジェクトと呼ばれますけれども、
ここでは、延べ12万人の科学者、技術者が動員されて、
30カ所以上の施設を作って、
金額としては20億ドル以上を費やした。
そういうふうにいわれておりますけども、
そんな国家規模の開発をしなくても、
21世紀の技術に関しては、GNRでありますけども、
これに関しては、場合によっては個人が
自分の自宅のガレージで、あるいは大学の一研究室で、
パーソナルコンピューターを使って
開発することができるようになる。
かつては大型計算機を駆使して何日もかかってやった
骨の折れる計算っていうのが、
今では個人のコンピューターで処理をすることが
可能でありますし、多くのスタッフが総出で
数カ月もかかってやったような調査が今では
インターネットを使って、あるいは人工知能の
AIを使って簡単に調べることができると。
このような環境の中で遺伝子工学、あるいは
ナノテクノロジー、あるいはロボット工学。
こういったものの開発は想像以上に簡単なことであると。
IT技術、コンピューターを含みますけれども、
この発展によって情報伝達のスピードと
規模っていうのは急激に広がっていると。進んでいると。
そうすると、そういったGNRに関しても
ひとたび新しい知見が生まれると、その情報というのが、
たとえ危険なものであったとしても、インターネットを
通じて世界中に広がってしまうわけなので、
そういった危険な情報の管理っていうのも
難しいであろうと。悪意を持った犯罪者や
テロリストたちにもこういう情報が
共有されてしまう可能性が高いと。
したがってと、ビル・ジョイは言うわけです。
21世紀の人類は、彼はこういうふうに言ってますね。
乗客全員がいつでも墜落ボタン、自爆ボタンを
押せる状態で飛んでいるジェット機、
これに乗っているようなものであると。
これらの科学技術は個人すなわち1人の技術者、
科学者が種としての人類全体の運命を
決定する能力を持っていると。
そういうことになるんだというわけですね。
ですから、われわれは、こういう危険性を
はらんでいる科学技術を扱うにあたっては
リスクを十分評価しなきゃいけないし、
新しい倫理規範というのを持たなきゃいけないと。
こういうふうに彼は考えてるわけですね。
ここにありますのが、スライドにありますのが、
彼が提唱するところの21世紀の技術者が、あるいは
科学者が持つべき倫理規範というものであります。
ぜひ一度、ゆっくり見ていただきたいと思います。
われわれ、そういう危険性が予測される場合には、
研究開発というものを制限し、情報の公開にも
配慮が必要であるとこういうふうに考えられるわけです。
核兵器の出現というものを防げなかった
20世紀の科学技術の専門家たち。
この専門家たちの失敗を繰り返してはならないと。
こういうふうにジョイは警告しているわけですね。
危険な技術の創出や拡散を防ぐために、
先ほど述べたような新しい倫理規範というのを
提唱してるわけです。ビル・ジョイが示した
未来像っていうのはあまりに
悲観的ではありますけれども、
科学技術と社会というマクロな関係を考えるうえで、
こういう注意深い考察が必要であること、
それが正しいことっていうのは、
東日本大震災によっても、ある意味
証明されてしまったということがいえると思います。
新しい時代の技術者っていうのは、
ジョイの批判を無視をして仕事を進めるというわけには
もういかないんじゃないかなと、
こういうふうに考えられます。でも、自分たちは
技術をさらに発展させるんだと、
それが技術者なわけですけれども、そういう人たちは
ビル・ジョイの懸念というものを払拭できるだけの、
そういう説明を自らできるように
ならなきゃいけないんじゃないかと私は思います。
ジョイの示した未来像っていうのが
悲観的だというのであれば、楽観的でいられるような、
そういう科学技術と社会の関係について
クリエイティブな、創造的な設計というものを行って、
その設計に従った世界を
構築していかなければならないと。
こういうふうに思います。
私は、その鍵となるのが、
何度も言っておりますけれども、よく生きること、
well-beingに関しての科学的な研究と、
そこから得られる成果というものを反映した
技術者倫理であるというふうに考えています。
既に議論しましたように、ポジティブ心理学の研究成果、
すなわち人間は自分よりも大きな存在のために
貢献することによってよく生きること、
well-beingを高めることができるんだと。
だからこそ、日常の業務の中で、PERMAですね、
これに関する考察、これに基づく意思決定と
行動を忘れることなく、定期的に俯瞰的な立場に立って、
マクロエシックスの視点から自分が携わっている
業務が公衆の福利に、well-beingにどのように
貢献してるのか、これを確認することによって、
自分自身の主観的な
幸福度を高めることができるわけです。
こういった互恵的な関係について、公衆との間で、
一般の人たちとの間でちゃんと
インフォームドコンセントというものを確立して
コンセンサスを築き上げるために、
技術者自らが自分の才能と知識、想像力、
こういったものを最大限生かして、
活用していかなければいけない、
じゃないかなというふうに思います。
このような時代だからこそ、科学技術を担う
技術者の広い視野に立った
マクロなレベルでの技術者倫理というものが
期待されていると思います。
報告書の中にもありましたけれども、
原子力村といわれるわけですけども、
原子力村の中に閉じこもっていてはいけないと
報告書は書いてありますけれども、往々にして
技術者の人たちは技術者村の中に
入ってしまうわけでありますので、
そういう技術者村にとらわれるのではなくて、
積極的に社会との対話というのを推進していくこと。
これは先ほどの学術会議の
行動規範の中にもありましたけれども、
それが新しい時代の技術者に求められている、
そういう必須の能力といえるんじゃないかと、
こういうふうに私は考えます。